mi devo pagare addosso mi stai dicendo
questo mi state dicendo che mi devo
pagarlo un giorno c'è il durello sotto
le lenzuola cos'è sta roba presidente
che grafica cia sto gioco santo iddio
che ansia non siamo in un posto dove
sale è un tipo sto dicendo pensate che
l'unico e con quella è una persona non
ride è l'unico videogioco horror che
gioco da una vita dove sono in mezzo
alla civiltà e quindi farebbe meno paura
del solito se non fosse che porca di una
[ __ ] è abbastanza raccapricciante come
scenario e come grafica però vabbè ma
che si sia fatto di pasticche il
personaggio di interagisci e non si apre
interagisce
comunque io non ho mai capito i
personaggi che per guardare lontano
disumano con gli occhi che cazzo cioè un
binocolo nella retina spiega mi dissero
che non le ho mai capito ma mai mai
capito mi sempre nello per il culo c'è
ancora il tipo di fuori non guardo
perché non si sa mai curiosità bene ad
un altro paio e sia un highlander action
non ha senso ho preso una chiave è
discusso spuntati due tizi fantastico è
decisamente sotto effetto di plastica e
sto tizio a ok ci avvolge la chiave
perfetto posso prendere il martello e
dario in testa per qualcosa non lo so
ditemelo
non posso prendere il martello bene o un
gioco serio porco e gli spot lo forzo lo
siete
devo smi chiare tutto il muro qua che
devo fare
sì però devi stare calmo e la madonna
no dai video vi sto ripetendo cos'è sta
roba interesse c'è una ragionare
nascosta dietro la stanza sembra che
anche lui scrive le cose ogni volta che
succede qualcosa quindi adesso che ho
spaccato il muro ha detto che c'è
un'aria nascosta dietro le stanze in
teoria non è possibile perché dovrebbero
scegliere appartamenti effettivamente
dietro un appartamento sei un condominio
c'è un altro appartamento non c'è un
muro a sfondare one direction ben kebede
queste date wed dei talk a troja e
michela vagina della mamma degli haters
questo entriamo appartamenti apartments
o la madonna sono l'inferno mi spiegate
le sto andando 9 c'è un'uscita c'è
un'uscita quanta ansia
[Musica]
che gioca brutto che questo ho trovato
una chiave di questo cristo arriva ogni
volta un punto nuovo poi torna tutto
indietro scrive un foglietto lo mette
sul tavolo e poi torna di nuovo lì che
problemi al cervello ai frati ho trovato
un cancello bloccato sì l'ho visto da
quando ho rotto il muro non mi fermerò
bene questa cosa avrei fatto lo stesso
anche senza tornare indietro però
direction
ok questi sono decisamente più di one
direction moltissimo
ripensandoci proviamo la porta ragazzi
non si apre che peccato
grazie anche qui non si capisce come
sono le cose
raga
[Musica]
se qualcuno soffre di crisi epilettiche
non guardi questo video troppo tardi il
cancello adesso è aperto guarda o più li
volevo andare 1 st voglia di andare nel
cancello stantia risultato perché
andiamo le cancello
porca eva dato non ho neanche visto
quanta gente ci sono io che non voglio
saperlo
sesso
paga perché c'è il rumore di una
motosega raga non c'è più nessuno
non c'e piu nessuno sono andati via ok
non è un buon segno che non c'è più
nessuno effettivamente perché potrebbero
essere visto credevo che mi ha superato
va bene che il gioco brutto due sono
bore chievo molto sibello che si sta
facendo non sta filmando rosa in mano
alla video cacace black mirror on the
scaricare chiudi è golena perché c'è la
maniglia saino non puoi far due cose
contemporaneamente già li prendi cura di
se ti metti curabile volte su ca su
carlo e lo guardi prendi questo eventi
questo ti piace è vero anche a tua madre
è piaciuto quindi questa è la vagina
della tua mamma la e la e lava e la
vagina della torah entriamo nella pagina
della tua mamma capiamo dove bisogna
andare cos'è sta roba
no
al cancello e il cancello ancora chiuso
tra l'altro si aperto permesso sono file
i jazz band ma ho chiuso un tipo che mi
riprendeva che non c'è l'autorizzazione
per i però il mio copyright non può
farlo in carica tutto su youtube dove
iniziò a questo punto si sa è un
corridoio
no no no frate fra ammazzo ti ammazzo ti
ammazzo te la stai la ha detto no ma
sono io questo work evans un fegato
addosso anche io sto riprende domanda
numero uno perché sta riprendendo
domanda numero 2 che cazzo hai fatto ai
capelli mai uscire di casa senza i
capelli dove li ha dimenticati domanda
al numero 3 per che cazzo sei vestito da
gualdo pronto perché porti lake instant
è sereno e confido vabbè a sono entrato
nello specchio che faccia brutta che ci
sembro io quando prendo i due a scuola
sembrava molto bello comunque io non lo
so diminuire un po la luminosità in
questo video giorgio non è proprio il
massimo
[Musica]
se non bastasse de che è successo è
successo
christoph frei 2016 watermark ei gioco
di merda sono felice io qua ho giocato
cinque minuti la gente si incazza se
finisce qui il gioco è capito anche
perché non ho capito bene potrei
ammazzarti il canarino di schiavi con lo
trovo lo ammazzo e lo costringo a
riguardare questo video 800 volte no
perché non ha senso che dire ragazzi è
stato un bel jong e sono contento di
condividere queste esperienze
videoludiche con tutti quanti voi sarete
contenti sicuramente anche voi però che
vi sia piaciuto questo video ragazzi
cava senza che invece l'argomento non mi
piace andiamocene facebook e come il mio
totale descrizione senza vestiti siete
lì ci rivediamo proseguito intendo
ragazzi